hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again and
welcome to part four of the hero concept
series they guys for keeping this series
alive but and well I've been having a
lot of fun making these videos and you
guys seem to be having a lot of fun
interacting with me and it's this nice
little collaborative video we get to
come together and make and as always if
you're new to this series you have your
chance to be in a video just by leaving
a comment down in the comments below
and any here that you want to be
realistic unrealistic anything like that
for example in the past video we talked
about a more realistic pirate idea
whereas the unrealistic idea was the
abyss watchers from Dark Souls so
obviously any option is completely fine
with me yeah today's gonna be chock-full
of some stuff we got a weapon and we got
some heroes some beautiful stuff to talk
about today so it's like to be if you do
enjoy subscribers renew a cover the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the patch notes and Elise if I
don't we kept it today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update deathly
stay subscribe the channel with that
let's get started with today's video so
first up is technically a hero concept
but there's a lot more focus on the
weapon and the hero as it's not has
talked about as much but I got a lot of
comments about this so here's a good
majority of what is on screen and that
would be the hero with nunchucks
honestly the more I think about it the
more I question why this hasn't happened
yet there's some my research I couldn't
really find an origin in terms of a
fighting or combat it was mostly just
theories about what they used it for
like banging it against wood to make a
sort of bail or for farming purposes but
of course thanks to the Bruce Lee movies
it's been widely popular as a fighting
object as of recent times even though
it's a very simple construction of two
sticks and something of a chain or a
rope to hold them together these are
anything but simple weapons to use right
away a ninja looking character similar
to shinobi would definitely be probably
wielding this weapon as for some of the
ideas though we could look to the Bruce
Lee movies or Liu Kang from Mortal
Kombat and specific now while the Bruce
Lee movies are extremely terrible
voice-over dubbing and very fake
scripted fighting they're still
extremely entertaining like this scene
on screen it can be really good for
emote whirling like the nunchucks are
ons in a circle or stuff and for this
instance while it makes no sense within
the context of the movie how he's able
to hit that many people at once you can
honestly use this move to trip people in
sweeps like with Valkyrie and it can
also have an ice deflector parry
animation for this move like trapping
the weapon in the nunchucks and then
going
hit afterwards moving on to Liu Kang a
top-heavy could be seen as a nice
overhead swing like this which kind of
actually could go into Shinobi's move
where he has that heavy attack and then
wants the heavy lands he can confirm a
very fast but low damage light attack
afterwards with a little bit of bleed
this would be kind of the same thing as
you're seeing with Liu Kang here except
obviously it wouldn't apply bleed just
be a simple heavy into very quick light
attack if it manages to land because
obviously they can make the top heavy of
this move very slow and then if it lands
the light afterwards can be confirmed as
this is a slow attack Liu Kang in Mortal
Kombat 11 also has an ability called
nunchuck stance for he can do many
different moves from this stance as well
these can be from hitting projectiles of
the air doing others you know different
moves sweeps etcetera obviously not all
of these would make sense of in the
context and the limits of the game just
like this multi hit combo would not work
within the game well it'd be cool I
think at least within for Honor's case
it could probably be an execution as
that's like five or six moves which is
like bigger than sickle rain so that'd
be extremely hard to even land to begin
with but swipes of course can work too
as we have side guard stances but maybe
not so much as uppercuts that can may be
once again be long for executions and
then of course liu kang speaking of
executions has a lot of fatalities and
it could definitely be used as an
inspiration for the nunchuck character
for obvious new monetization reasons I
won't be showing them but let's say one
of them definitely consists of snapping
the neck of the opponent with the
nunchucks and I think that'd be really
cool to have for the character as well
it's not as gruesome as Mortal Kombat we
do have some decapitation bone-breaking
type of executions in the game so that's
not out of the reason that it would
never be added it just obviously
wouldn't be as graphic as Mortal Kombat
would be another highly requested hero
is someone from the Ottoman Empire it
was never proposed what the specific
person would be so I'll just go with the
Janus series I believe is the
pronunciation of this warrior
they were elite warriors that were
within the first modern standing army in
Europe it said by the early 1600s they
had about 37,000 troops of just that
specific warrior so obviously they had
many warriors as well sadly though while
they were really powerful at the time of
course Western Europe was beginning to
evolve and modernize and they refused to
change with the times they're very
stubborn which eventually led to a
rebellion and their Corps becoming
abolished while some of them had left
most of them were executed while this
army mostly did use guns they also had a
yachtie guns swords that looked like
this on screen it was their version of a
traditional saber weapon and was used to
not hinder them while carrying it on
their waist while marching here's some
of the pictures on-screen and I think
they look really cool and I saw this
picture from art station that I think
would be super sick for the legendary
gear and why don't you guys think about
that I think that would be an absolutely
banger customization set and I think a
lot of people would be using that if the
character did come to the game next up
is from a man named Oliver and he says
the winged hasar Xand I've seen a couple
of these mentioned as well and I
personally not sure if the wings would
actually fit maybe they could be a
smaller version as an ornament but I'd
be totally down for this if they could
incorporate this somehow they were also
a cavalry unit and that would obviously
not fit in the game as we don't have any
horses within this game that people
could use so obviously no horseback but
I still think that they could still be
part of this game and their main weapon
on horseback was Lance's and while they
did use traditional sabers and other
swords I think having a lance would be a
nice addition to this game as we really
don't have anything like that yet
excluding a character like Valkyrie that
has a spear which is pretty close to a
lance I still think that this could work
and I also think that the his-- ours
would definitely be within the Knights
faction or maybe something that
definitely isn't Viking so it wouldn't
be a kind of copy-paste of Valkyrie in
the sense and obviously there's loads of
different Lance's when it comes to stuff
like this there's the more realistic
what looking ones but then there's stuff
like a monster hunter which has a
disgustingly huge lance that I'm just
surprised that the characters can even
carry it to begin with
obviously a more realistic one would
definitely suffice and I think this
would be really cool I don't know too
much about the house ARS and maybe now
the more that I think about it I think
the wings could definitely be part of
the faction or part of this group and
somehow fit with them maybe it might not
be an ornament it could actually be a
full type of legendary gear but then you
have to take into account the wing
effect that we just recently got how
would that fit that's kind of what that
is but maybe you could have like a weird
combination of it with like smaller
wings on the armor but bigger wings you
know maybe during an execution I guess
that there's some kind of story you
could fit with that type of armor maybe
that's just the kind of the way that I
was thinking about it personally
regardless though avoid that they add
the wings or not to the character I
think the character in general and the
idea
that they come from and all the story
behind it I think would be a really nice
fit for for honor as we really don't
have anything too close to this
character so it'd be a nice addition to
this game regardless the last hero we
have for today is actually a slide show
that a guy named don't yodel so hard has
sent me for the peasant hero
I won't go completely in-depth as he put
a lot of work and I'd rather not show
off every single thing as I believe that
this needs to be seen by everybody
individually so if you do want to see
his entire slide show this goes over
movesets customization story all that
kind of thing for this character a lot
of different cool ideas with his own
little drawings it's actually really
dope I'll leave it in the description if
you want to check this out yourself so
like I said the original name of the
character is going to be called the
peasant the original idea for the
peasant was you know since back in the
day in the medieval times peasants were
mostly farmers and that's why he wants
the hero to wield a scythe if you had no
idea sites were actually used as farming
tools so this would definitely make
sense it's not your traditional more
modern version of the size I had a
couple handles on the bottom and towards
the middle as so that they can swing it
whereas modern-day sites have no handle
like that it's just a long stick with a
curvy blade so it's obviously going to
be using the farming version but it
could maybe be upgraded to that version
you know the more curvy looking one with
no handles as a legendary option he also
came up with some moves like I said a
couple of them being a CC move that can
push the enemy behind you with the curve
style of the scythe kind of dragging
them away and also he came up with a
move that is an unarmed dodge attack
that goes in the opposite direction of
your button input' kind of like soon
DAWs light attack overall I think a
character with a scythe would be pretty
sick obviously I don't really know how
the customization will work obviously
you know bare bones level one peasant
would have some dirty rags or something
like that
and then maybe at a more higher tier
could actually get some decent looking
armor as I would assume in terms of a
peasant story the peasant would be going
around and killing people and grabbing
and using their armor it may be for some
story due to the peace and prosperity
going around with this new season maybe
that's allowing him to know maybe
realize that oh these guys are the true
enemies he doesn't really believe in
this kind of treaty and he's gonna ruin
it or because of all this peace it's
absolutely it's actually making him you
know feel a lot better about the world
and he's
to join the ranks of these other
warriors instead of just being a common
peasant so maybe it turns out to be a
good thing in within his storyline hey
guys it's gonna be the end of the Vita
hopefully guys did enjoy it like I said
if you want to join and end up
participating in a future video just
leave a comment down below of a hero
that you want to be featured with in the
game whatever like I said it can be
realistic could be unrealistic totally
up to you and yeah just leave your
comment down below and hopefully get
picked I try to do as many people as I
can but also not try to make these
videos 15 to 20 minutes because those
can be a bit long and not everybody I
understand what I want to watch all that
but either way like I said that's gonna
be the end of the today's video guys
hopefully you guys did enjoy it with
that like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the patch notes in the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out don't
update if we subscribe the channel
and with that take Arius ever girls
today I'll see you in the next video
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]